New York City apartments are small like
really small
to combat this ever shrinking urban
dilemma a company of MIT called Ori is
building Louisville modular and get this
totally automatic furniture for people
living in close quarters
Auri that short for origami is like a
21st century update to the Murphy bed
instead of pulling it bed from the wall
you simply have to press a button or say
a command to make the furniture move for
$10,000 you can get automatic furniture
at the press of a button or by syncing
with an Amazon echo okay a little-known
feature about Ori
it also doubles as a great way to get
around your apartment hey Alexa tell Ori
to show me my closet
[Music]
city studios are notoriously tight on
space but Ori turns your entire
apartment into a walk-in closet think of
worry like a self-driving car only for
your home you plug the unit into a
regular outlet and it's wheels glide
along a track that's attached to the
wall a series of small motors are hidden
inside the furniture to make it move
left and right Aria has three main
tricks it expands to a walk-in closet
compacts to Korea a spacious lounge and
most importantly it hides messy sheets
in the mere seconds you'll never have to
make your bed again the furniture
doesn't magically increase your studious
square footage but it does allow you to
make the most of the space you have as
more people move to cities and
apartments get smaller robotic furniture
like Cory is only gonna become more
common weird maybe a little but there
are some perks too hey Alexa tell Ori to
bring me my wine
[Music]
it's not exactly a robotics bartender
but it'll do the trick
[Music]